one of the common mitigation strategies
we can use during an incident
is to simply add capacity to handle
unexpected traffic or load
however this only works if there's
capacity available running on a resource
quarter can
make a minor incident into a major one
today
i'll show you how to keep track of quota
usage in your projects with cloud
monitoring
this is the stackdoctor
[Music]
google cloud enforces quotas on resource
usage for project owners
setting a hard limit on how much of a
particular google cloud resource your
project can use
let's start by reviewing the basics
there are two types of resource usage
that we limit with quota
the first one is rate quota such as api
requests per day
this quarter resets after a specified
time such as a minute or a day
the second one is allocation quota such
as the number of service recounts
created in your project
this quota does not reset over time but
must be explicitly released typically by
deleting the resource
you can see quotas in your project by
going to the quarter screen under the
iam and admin menu
from there you can see all the quotas in
your project and how much of them you're
using
you can use this to figure out if you're
out of a particular quarter and that's
great
but how can you be more proactive about
this and prevent quota limits from
getting in your way
especially when you need more capacity
quickly
well the good news is that you can get
this information in cloud monitoring
and even set up alerts against them
let's take a look
you can use the consumer quota resource
to see the available metrics
there are two quota usage metrics for
rate and allocation
there's a metric for the quota limit and
finally a metric showing you how many
times you've actually hit that limit
called quota exceeded error start by
selecting the quarter limit metric
then filter it to just the logging
service and the write request per minute
limit
in my project that limit is set to 60
thousand that's a lot of logging
now let's add another metric showing how
much of that limit we're actually using
this time use the rate quota usage
metric and again filter it to the
logging service
in my case i'm nowhere near the limit
this is good news
finally you can configure an alerting
policy that you can notify you if you
actually hit quota limits on your
project
use the consumer quota resource in the
condition configuration
and select quota exceeded error as the
metric now group it by service
and configure the alert to fire any time
series exceed the threshold
now you'll know if you hit any quota
limits in the project
you should know that not all services
support quota metrics at this point
refer to the documentation link that
we'll add to the show notes for details
on that
monitoring quota usage in your project
is a great way to proactively make sure
you always have the capacity you need
if there's an unexpected spike in
traffic thanks for watching and come
back soon for more
this is the stackdoctor stay healthy out
[Music]
there
you